chers amis je voudrais d'abord féliciter
luc chatel pour son élection à la
présidence de ce conseil national et
remercier michèle alliot marie pour son
engagement militant et gaullistes notre
conseil national a pour objet de
débattre de notre ligne politique
c'est une bonne chose c'est une bonne
chose sous réserve de ne pas oublier
qu'une ligne politique
c'est le résultat d'un projet pour la
france ça ne peut pas être le fruit
d'une synthèse hollande yens
la synthèse c'est pour les démocraties
tranquille et c'est pour les pays riches
en mes amis nous n'en sommes plus là
notre nation s'enfonce et elle est au
bord de la révolte
le jour où la banque centrale européenne
arrêtera de faire tourner la planche à
billets et où nos taux d'intérêt
remonteront alors on arrêtera de donner
des leçons à la grèce parce que nous
serons comme athènes à genou à genou
devant nos créanciers et à genoux
surtout devant les français qui nous
réclamons des comptes françois hollande
joue les pères de la nation qui
l'appauvrît par son impuissance et
qu'ils divisent par ces manoeuvres
politiciennes plutôt que de remanier son
gouvernement il aurait mieux fait de
remanier sa politique
il dit vouloir réformer jusqu'au bout
mais il n'a jamais commencé
il renvoie aux électeurs le soin de lui
dire s'il faut faire ou non
l'aéroport de notre dame des landes en
juillet 2012
j'avais écrit une tribune dans le figaro
je disais à françois hollande devenez le
chef de l'état est bien quatre ans après
je repose la question est ce qu'il y a
un chef
et est ce qu'il y à un état la vérité
la vérité c'est que son bilan est
calamiteux champion des impôts champion
du chômage champion de la dette
champion des apparences avec maquereau
en tête de gondole qui parle mais qui
n'agit pas est aussi champion des
promesses a battu par la réalité
la cour des comptes vient de préciser
que le contrat de génération qui était
en première page du programme de
françois hollande était un échec et s'il
n'y avait que cet échec comme vous tous
je rencontre toutes les semaines des
agriculteurs performant qui travaillent
90 heures par semaine et qui ne peuvent
plus verser de salaire à la fin du mois
et on s'étonne ensuite que le monde
agricole sont à bout de nerfs
je vois des entrepreneurs et des
artisans qui paie tellement de
cotisation tellement d'impôt tellement
de taxes que leur revenu est inférieur
au salaire minimum
je vois dans nos cités des habitants au
bord de l'explosion
la vérité c'est que la france est
bloquée et que la paupérisation s'étend
le président de la république a
récemment décrété l'état d'urgence
économique des mots encore des mots
toujours des mots en fête d'urgence on
va réfléchir au code du travail
on va multiplier les primes al embauche
on va relancer l'apprentissage après
l'avoir cassé on va recycler pour la
énième fois les vieilles recettes qui
n'ont jamais fonctionné
françois hollande est impopulaire mais
ça serait excusable s'il l'était pour
avoir dit la vérité et pour avoir
cherché réellement à réformer notre pays
ça serait pardonnable si le continent
européen tout entier était en panne
économique
mais voilà pendant qu'on parle ici
la grande bretagne et l'allemagne sont
en plein emploi et leur croissance est
largement supérieure à la nôtre
nous sommes à la traîne et ce faisant le
gouvernement français non seulement ne
pilote plus l'europe mais il fait part
son impéritie le jeu de tous ceux qui
accusent bruxelles de nos problèmes
françois hollande n'a aucune vision de
l'europe au début de son mandat
souvenez-vous il a lâchement accusé
berlin d'être un frein à la croissance
européenne alors que le france était lui
sur la question des réfugiés
il a laissé angela merkel agir seul et
engagé l'europe dans une impasse face à
la menace du bric site
on est dans les petits arrangements au
lieu de refonder l'europe autour des
grandes priorités de notre temps une
europe autour d'une monnaie puissante
qui serait capable de nous affranchir en
fin de la tutelle exorbitante du dollar
que dénonçait déjà en son temps le
général de gaulle une politique de
l'énergie européenne pour ne pas être
totalement dépendant de la russie une
politique de frontières et d'immigration
commune une défense collective pour
endiguer les menaces qui n'ont jamais
été aussi fortes depuis 30 ans sur le
continent européen
et puis une grande stratégie pour
l'innovation et le numérique qui ferait
des européens la première puissance
technologique au monde je veux l'europe
mais avec la france debout disait
philippe séguin
eh bien mon cher philippe
mon cher philippe aujourd'hui l'une et
l'autre sont à terre et moi j'enrage de
voir la civilisation européenne
doutaient de son sort
au milieu des orages j'accuse françois
hollande et sa diplomatie de ne pas
s'être donné tous les moyens de détruire
l'état islamique
il a fallu trois ans pour qu'il
comprenne enfin qu'il fallait frapper
les fanatiques en syrie il lui a fallu
trois ans pour qu'il comprenne enfin
qu'il faudrait une vraie coalition
internationale pour abattre leurs
drapeaux noirs maintenant vous avez le
spectacle sous vos yeux
la russie a agi seul avec l'iran et les
bras ballants nous attendons l'issue des
événements depuis deux mois le
gouvernement nous fait débattre de la
déchéance de nationalité et de l'état
d'urgence qui existe déjà dans nos lois
et ils nous imposent de réviser la
constitution chacun de vous à son avis
sur cette question et il est respectable
vous connaissez le mien je les exprime
et en conscience comme vous tous je suis
évidemment favorable à la déchéance des
terroristes pas de pitié pour ceux qui
sont sans pitié
mais
mais je ne suis pas aux ordres de
françois hollande et de ses
improvisations
ce que je n'accepte pas c'est qu'on
touche à notre constitution pour rien
pendant qu'on occulte les vrais
problèmes
les vrais problèmes c'est l'efficacité
de notre lutte contre l' état islamique
en syrie les vrais problèmes c'est le
renforcement des dispositifs de sécurité
de renseignement qui ont montré des
failles les vrais problèmes c'est le
combat contre le salafisme qui ronge
l'islam en france
les vrais problèmes c'est la bataille
contre le chômage de masse qui mine
notre jeunesse mes amis ma ligne
politique est clair il faut battre la
gauche et il faut changer ce système
économique et social qui nous tue à
petit feu
avec 20 ans de croissance molle six
millions de français qui pointe à pôle
emploi
deux mille milliards de dette deux
millions de jeunes qui ne sont ni à
l'école ni dans un emploi c'est bien
plus qu'un problème de gauche ou de
droite c'est le problème de tout un
système qui est usée jusqu'à la corde
durant des décennies on a laissé
entendre que l'état pouvait tout et que
les citoyens lui devait tout on a
préféré le traitement social du chômage
plutôt que d'assouplir le marché de
l'emploi on a choisi les impôts plutôt
que la réduction des dépenses publiques
on a cultivé la précaution plutôt que le
risque
voilà le poison dont il faut nous guérir
et pour cela il faut un changement
radical pour cela il faut changer de
logiciel on ne va pas relancer la france
avec de l'argent public
les caisses sont vides on va pas
colmater les brèches avec des impôts et
des règlements
les français n'en peuvent plus il reste
une seule solution une solution qui est
la plus efficace et la plus belle cette
solution elle est simple faire confiance
à la liberté qui est la première valeur
de notre devis
et l'étincelle du progrès aujourd'hui
malgré tous leurs efforts les français
voient leur existence coincé alors que
la vie est faite pour être vécu à fond
avec l'espoir de saisir ses rêves
on a tout niveler toutes encadrées au
nom d'un misérabilisme bout tu veux
créer ton entreprise commence pas
remplir les formulaires tu veux
travailler le dimanche va demander la
permission aux syndicats tu veux
travailler plus gagner plus transmettre
à ses enfants le fruit des efforts pense
d'abord aux impôts que tu vas payer
comment peut-on dans ces conditions
stimuler les français et pourtant j'en
suis certain donner au français la
liberté dosée et vous verrez que leur
audace nous mènera très haut
notre priorité doit être de créer une
france productive une france du plein
emploi
il ne faut pas avoir peur de chevaux une
preuve on sent que chacun a la capacité
de prendre l'initiative
il faut baisser les charges sur le
travail il faut donner aux entrepreneurs
la liberté de négocier le temps de
travail avec leurs salariés et il faut
vraiment le faire sans fixer à l'avance
des contraintes il faut généraliser
l'apprentissage
il faut transférer les lycées
professionnels aux régions il faut
réformer l'assurance chômage et
instaurer la dégressivité des
allocations
oui moi je veux avec vous moins de
charges moins d'impôts et plus de
confiance pour ceux qui font tourner les
moteurs de l'économie française
je veux remettre nos finances publiques
en ordre
parce que les dents les déficits
vampirise nos capacités d'investissement
et pour ça il n'y a pas 36 solutions il
faut réduire le nombre de fonctionnaires
il faut passer aux 39 heures dans les
fonctions publiques
il faut rapprocher les départements et
les régions il faut porter l'âge de la
retraite à 65 ans sans tergiverser alors
oui tout ça est radical mais mes amis
c'est radical parce que la situation est
radicalement bloquer les socialistes
prétendent défendre le modèle social
mais de quel modèle par le tilt le
conservatisme et antisociales ne devons
nous être le parti des jeunes qui se
cassent les dents sur la rigidité du
marché du travail
nous devons être le parti des chômeurs
qui préfère bosser le dimanche plutôt
que de pointer à pôle emploi le lundi
nous devons être le parti des ouvriers
qui préfèrent travailler un peu plus
plutôt que de ne pas travailler du tout
nous devons être partis des
entrepreneurs des artisans des
agriculteurs qui prennent des risques
oui il faut libérer notre force
productive mais il faut aussi renforcer
l'autorité républicaine
depuis plusieurs mois le président de la
république et le premier ministre n'ont
pas d'autre mot à la bouche que la
république la république c'est un
système institutionnel nous ne sommes
pas un système
nous sommes la république française
c'est à dire une république avec son
histoire avec sa culture avec ses
traditions avec ses valeurs
dans la république française
l'école transmet aux enfants le respect
des autres et celui de son pays qu'à la
suite des attentats
les minutes de silence ait pu être
perturbée c'est une honte que dans nos
quartiers d adolescence interpelle en
fonction de leur origine est
inadmissible gaulois fudge beurre blacks
cette régression tribale est contraire à
l'idée que nous nous faisons ensemble de
la france unie s'il faut rappeler que
nous sommes tous français est tous égaux
et bien rétablissons l'uniforme à
l'école
imposons une morale civique qui ne soit
pas un bavardage resteront l'autorité et
soutenons les enseignants qui ne désarme
pas c'est bien plus crucial est bien
plus urgent que la suppression de
l'article circonflexe
dans la république française les
derniers arrivants ont des devoirs avant
de réclamer des droits
je veux réduire l'immigration à son
strict minimum en fixant des quotas
annuels en fonction de nos besoins
économiques et de nos capacités
d'intégration
je veut conditionner les aides sociales
à au moins deux années de présence en
france
je veux préciser à ce que nous avons
choisi d'accueillir ce que nous exigeons
d'eux un travail la volonté de
s'approprier notre langue et nos règles
communes
chacun a ses différences et je les
reconnais mais la fraternité ne va pas
sans la communion nationale dans la
république française la laïcité ne
recule pas comme la demande et
courageusement l'imam d'alfortville je
le cite il faut nettoyer les mosquées
salafistes et mes amis
ce que l'état a autrefois exigé de la
religion catholique
il n'y a aucune raison qu'ils ne
puissent pas aujourd'hui l'exigé des
autres religions et en particulier de la
religion musulmane mais la fermeté ne
dépend pas seulement de l'état et je
veux dire aujourd'hui ici aussi qu'il
revient à nos concitoyens musulmans de
se soulever contre ceux qui
instrumentalisent leurs fois parce que
c'est aussi une bataille idéologique et
une bataille spirituel que nous devons
mener ensemble le mariage pour tous a
profondément divisé la société française
je veut réécrire le droit de la
filiation pour protéger les droits de
l'enfant mes chers amis nous débutons un
siècle difficile qui vient défier notre
force d'âme mais je voulais sur six en
2017 nous choisissons enfin de faire si
nous sommes mandatés par les français
pour appliquer un projet sans concession
parce que nous aurons eu le courage
d'être élu pour cela alors je vous le
certifie notre pays peut effectuer son
retournement en deux ans il peut
atteindre le plein emploi en cinq ans et
il peut en l'espace de dix ans prétendre
à être la première puissance européenne
il ya des millions de français dévoué
ingénieux qui sont prêts à se retrousser
les manches et quand je les regarde je
ne voit dans leurs yeux ni lâcheté ni
résignation je vois simplement une force
qui attend son heure
alors tous ensemble allons au devant de
cette force et de ce rendez vous décisif
pour notre pays